Summer's almost here, which means blockbuster
season is kicking into gear.
The month of May saw new trailers for upcoming
superhero films, hard-rocking biopics, heart-pounding
horror flicks, and everything in between.
In fact, we're already getting trailers for
movies coming out as far away as November,
so hold on tight, this is going to be a wild
ride.
Here are all the trailers released in May
2018 that are sure to blow you away.
Upgrade
Each new trailer for Upgrade raises the stakes,
making this look like one of the most unique
surprises of 2018.
Logan Marshall-Green stars as Grey Trace,
a technophobe in the near-future who's implanted
with a computer chip that turns him into a
supercharged fighting machine.
Early critic screenings have come out largely
positive, with the general consensus being
that Upgrade is a fun, action-packed, and
supremely violent movie, perfect for kicking
off the summer blockbuster season.
With Leigh Whannell, creator of horror franchises
Saw and Insidious, pulling writing and directing
duties on Upgrade, you can count on a double
dose of insanity.
Look for it in theaters on June 1st.
Sicario: Day of the Soldado
Josh Brolin and Benicio del Toro are back
in the latest trailer for Sicario: Day of
the Soldado, reprising their roles from 2015's
surprise gangland hit.
This time, they're working to create a cartel
war in Mexico, using every means at their
disposal to escalate the violence and murders.
Judging by the trailer, it's bound to be everything
that made the first one great and then some.
Sicario: Day of the Soldado is set to premiere
in theaters on June 29th.
Escape Plan 2
There won't be a theatrical release for Escape
Plan 2, but that doesn't mean it's skimping
on the action, or the star power.
Sylvester Stallone returns as Ray Breslin,
who was wrongly imprisoned in the first Escape
Plan.
This time, he's putting himself behind bars
on purpose so that he can break out a prisoner
holding onto some sensitive information.
It's a race against time to find the valuable
prisoner before assassins can take him out,
and then it's a race against even less time
to get out of the prison alive.
Dave Bautista joins the crew, and 50 Cent
is returning as well.
You can check it out when Escape Plan 2 hits
Blu-ray and on-demand on June 29th.
Ant-Man and the Wasp
More than perhaps any other Marvel property,
Ant-Man thrives on its fantastic visuals,
and the latest trailer for Ant-Man and the
Wasp promises so much size-swapping it'll
make your head spin.
Most exciting though is the introduction of
the film's villain, Ghost.
Originally introduced in the comic pages as
an enemy of Iron Man, Ghost is an anti-corporate
anarchist who uses a high-tech suit to pass
through solid matter.
That extra element is bound to lead to some
insane fight sequences.
Look for Ant-Man and the Wasp in theaters
on July 6th.
Bleeding Steel
Jackie Chan is back in action with this summer's
Bleeding Steel, a sci-fi wonderland populated
by fancy headgear, colorful lights, and skintight
leather.
Okay, so the trailer leaves a lot to be desired,
but it showcases some interesting concepts
and, of course, Jackie Chan kicking people.
So many people.
Bleeding Steel is going straight to video
on demand, and there are probably worse ways
to spend an evening at home.
Look for it on July 6th.
Skyscraper
In case you still weren't sure what Skyscraper
is about, the latest trailer lays it out pretty
clearly.
Former FBI agent Will Sawyer lost his leg
in an explosion, and now he examines buildings
for a living to see if they have any security
flaws.
While he's in China consulting for the world's
new tallest building, terrorists attack the
building and frame him for the job.
Since his family's inside, he has to escape
the police and get inside.
Don't worry, he makes it, and takes out the
terrorists one by one.
Sounds like fun.
Dwayne Johnson and director Rawson Marshall
Thurber previously collaborated on Central
Intelligence, and this newest team-up hits
theaters on July 13th.
The Death of Superman
Say what you want about the DCEU, but DC runs
the game on animated films, and The Death
of Superman looks like a great new addition
to the animated line.
This adaptation of the iconic 1990s crossover
event sees Superman facing off against the
bloodthirsty monster Doomsday in an fight
that may just see the end of the Kryptonian
superhero.
And if you're thinking, "Haven't I seen this
cartoon before?" you're absolutely right!
DC's 2007 animated film Superman: Doomsday
was a lackluster attempt to combine all three
parts of the comic arc into one film.
The upcoming Death of Superman is slated to
be the first in a two-parter, allowing more
of the story to unfold on-screen.
Look for it on July 24th.
Mission: Impossible - Fallout
Despite multiple sequels, the Mission: Impossible
franchise has never failed to disappoint.
Well, after the second one at least.
In the latest trailer for Mission: Impossible
- Fallout, we learn that, once again, the
government doesn't trust Ethan Hunt to get
an important job done.
Forced to go rogue, Hunt and his loyal team
have to track down a nuclear weapon while
staying two steps ahead of the CIA and their
superspy August Walker, played by Henry Cavill.
The stakes are just as high as ever, the stunts
are just as real, and the mission is just
as impossible.
Check out Mission: Impossible - Fallout when
it lands in theaters on July 27th.
Mile 22
Starring Mark Wahlberg, Mile 22 follows a
special forces operative who's tasked with
protecting a police officer who knows the
location of nine pounds of missing radioactive
bomb material.
The trailer builds up the initial premise
without giving too many details away, instead
focusing on Mark Wahlberg's gunslinging skills
and Iko Uwais' insane martial arts.
The high-stakes action thrill ride is set
to hit theaters on August 3rd.
The HappyTime Murders
If the Muppets were in a gangland drama written
by Sacha Baron Cohen and directed by Seth
Rogen, it might look a lot like The HappyTime
Murders, a raunchy, profanity-laden comedy
about a world where puppets and humans live
together.
When someone starts murdering a bunch of famous
puppets, two detectives embark on a journey
through the seedy underbelly of puppetville
to solve the case.
What's actually surprising about this is that
it's directed and co-produced by Jim Henson's
son, Brian Henson, who previously directed
such family fare as The Muppet Christmas Carol
and Muppet Treasure Island.
The HappyTime Murders hits theaters on August
17th.
Down a Dark Hall
Uma Thurman is front and center in the new
trailer for Down a Dark Hall as headmaster
of a creepy boarding school for girls where
something sinister may be lurking in the hallways
at night.
Based on a novel by Lois Duncan, Down a Dark
Hall follows troubled young Kit Gordy who's
transferred to Blackwood Boarding School and
finds herself face-to-face with a supernatural
threat.
The trailer is heavy on the atmosphere, introducing
a faceless cloaked man, creepy occult rituals,
and the implication there are definitely sinister
happenings going down.
Take a look on August 17th.
Papillon
The story of a man who's wrongly convicted
of murder and sentenced to life in a brutal
prison in French Guiana, Papillon focuses
on his harrowing escape from prison and his
adventures in the tropics after he gets out.
Starring Charlie Hunnam as Papillon and Rami
Malek as his fellow escapee, Papillon looks
like it hits all the right beats for a remake.
It has adventure, high-stakes prison escaping,
and a love story holding it all together.
Papillon sails into theaters on August 24th.
City of Lies
There's a lot to take in from the first trailer
for City of Lies.
Twenty years after the murders of Tupac Shakur
and Biggie Smalls, a journalist tracks down
the detective who was in charge of the case
- Russell Poole, played by Johnny Depp.
As he digs deeper, he uncovers a twisted conspiracy
involving the LAPD and the local gangs, and
he's quick to learn that when you open a scar
that's been closed for twenty years, blood
is bound to flow.
Depp is in top form as the jaded detective,
but it's Forest Whitaker who really shines
in the trailer as journalist Jack Jackson.
Check out City of Lies when it hits theaters
on September 7th.
The Predator
Shane Black's Predator film finally released
its first teaser, dropping the extraterrestrial
hunter right in the suburbs of Middle America.
The teaser doesn't give away many plot details,
leaving the big surprises for the film itself…
or maybe just future trailers.
The preview begins with a young boy playing
with some kind of alien transmitter device,
apparently calling the Predator to Earth.
Then, we're introduced to Boyd Holbrook's
character, a soldier who saw the alien when
its ship crashed.
The Predator was written by Shane Black and
Fred Dekker, who previously teamed up for
1987's The Monster Squad.
Look for The Predator in theaters on September
14th.
Mowgli
Sure, we just saw a high-profile live-action
version of The Jungle Book in 2016, but it
never went in a direction quite like this.
Don't expect any ditties about the Bear Necessities
in Mowgli, which promises a darker take on
the young boy's jungle upbringing.
Motion capture legend Andy Serkis directs
the film and voices Baloo.
Christian Bale, Benedict Cumberbatch, and
Cate Blanchett also lend their voices to the
film.
Mowgli arrives in theaters on October 19th.
Bohemian Rhapsody
Mr. Robot finally finds somebody to love in
the first trailer for Bohemian Rhapsody, a
bio-pic about the iconic rock band Queen.
Rami Malek is transformed as frontman Freddie
Mercury in the trailer, sporting the rocker's
legendary mustache and all his on-stage swagger.
Bohemian Rhapsody traces the band's formation,
their rise to fame, and one of Mercury's final
performances at the 1985 Live Aid concert.
Mike Myers is also slated to appear in the
film, along with Game of Thrones' Aidan Gillen.
Production on the bio-pic has been notoriously
troubled, with original director Bryan Singer
getting the boot in December 2017 after reports
of him clashing with Rami Malek.
Dexter Fletcher was brought in to finish the
film and oversee post-production.
Hopefully the onscreen drama doesn't suffer
due to the behind-the-scenes drama.
You can find out when Bohemian Rhapsody premieres
on November 2nd.
Robin Hood
It'd be easy to call the upcoming Robin Hood
film a knock-off of the non-stop-insanity
style of movies like Kingsmen.
But hey, if you get an action movie where
you can actually see the action, everybody
wins.
Filled with slo-mo arrow fights and exploding
horse-drawn carts, Robin Hood definitely looks
like a cheesily overblown take on the story,
but there's no denying that it's a feast for
the eyes.
Starring Taron Egerton, Jamie Foxx, and Ben
Mendelsohn, Robin Hood will follow the familiar
tale: disgusted with the corrupt government,
super archer Robin makes it his mission to
steal from the rich and give to the poor.
Look for it in theaters on November 21st.
The Sisters Brothers
It's a fact: The world needs more good Westerns,
and it looks like The Sisters Brothers is
set to deliver.
For starters, it has an amazing cast.
John C. Reilly and Joaquin Phoenix star, with
Jake Gyllenhaal, Riz Ahmed, and Rutger Hauer
co-starring.
The story follows the infamous hitmen the
Sisters brothers who are hired to track down
a gold prospector who stole from a local crime
boss, kicking off a darkly comic adventure
in the old West.
The trailer promises a hilarious journey anchored
by the chemistry between Phoenix and Reilly,
who play the skilled yet dysfunctional brothers.
With so much talent onboard, The Sisters Brothers
is definitely a movie to keep an eye on.
You can find it in theaters sometime in fall
2018.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!